hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta emisión nos
acompaña la actriz argentina telma
fardín thelma muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en la entrevista de plan 24 es
un placer que estés con nosotros
nos hayas santiago muchas gracias
gracias por la invitación no por favor
gracias a ti y nuevamente bueno thelma
era diciembre de 2018 cuando rompiste el
silencio y le hiciste a compañía y
contenida por decenas de mujeres que
hacen parte del colectivo de actrices
argentinas aquel día tuviste la fuerza
para decir lo que durante años había
guardado y denuncias te finalmente al
actor argentino juan darthés por abuso
sexual ocurrido en nicaragua cuando
tenías 16 años y el 45 esto ocurrió para
que sepan nuestra audiencia
internacional durante una gira de la
serie de televisión patito feo la
denuncia dio inicio a un proceso
judicial que involucra a tres países
argentina nicaragua y brasil recordemos
que la justicia nicaragüense emitió una
alerta internacional para la detención
del actor del arte es que ya había sido
denunciado por otras actrices pero él
huyó a brasil de donde es oriundo porque
la ciudadanía brasileña lo protegía y
por qué porque brasil no permite la
extradición de sus ciudadanos salvo
algunas excepciones pero se los puede
juzgar por delitos cometidos en otros
países en 2021 terman comenzó el juicio
y hace muy pocos días con el proceso
llegamos a su etapa final un tribunal
superior de brasil adujo a cuestiones
técnicas respecto de lo que es la
competencia jurisdiccional verdad y se
volvió la causa a fojas cero tema aquí
mensaje está dando la justicia
santiago este es claramente un mensaje
de impunidad de hasta qué lugares puede
llegar el poder lo que es muy
impresionante es que como vos decís
estábamos ya prácticamente sobre el
final del juicio faltaban solamente dos
audiencias y hubo esta decisión del
tribunal en la cual están incumpliendo
con muchísimos tratados internacionales
porque volver a hacer declarar a una
víctima es absolutamente revictimizan te
incumple con la convención de belem do
para de la cual brasil es parte con las
recomendaciones de la cedaw y lo que es
más doloroso es que además en argentina
esto no podría suceder entonces para mí
es muy difícil comprender todos los
vericuetos que tiene la
justicia brasilera que está discutiendo
la competencia una vez no sólo iniciado
el juicio sino allá en su recta final
thelma bueno vos hablabas de la
revictimización no hablaremos de eso un
poco más adelante en la entrevista pero
la víctima se le exige en prueba física
se le exige también muchísimo hay muchas
voces que salen a decir por lo general
bueno tiene que denunciarlo en tiempo en
forma en un determinado momento en un
determinado contexto no pareciera que
hay como una suerte de buena víctima
verdad
si las exigencias
lamentablemente son siempre para con la
víctima es el único delito este en el
mundo el único delito en el que la
primera y la única en ser peritada es la
víctima
y yo cuando viaje a nicaragua me me
hicieron una pericia siquiátrica una
pericia psicológica y a pesar de que
parezca ridículo también una pericia
física a pesar de que lo que yo
denunciaba había ocurrido nueve años
atrás y la justicia me permitía hacer la
denuncia porque hay que decir esto yo
tuve la suerte de que mi caso no
estuviera prescripto pero de todas
maneras en todo lo que va del proceso
solamente yo fui peritada
psicológicamente ya más de siete veces
incluso durante el proceso judicial por
parte de la defensa del arte se pusieron
una psicóloga y la de la defensa me pudo
hacer una pericia una cosa rarísima
porque una vez que está producida toda
la prueba es muy poco común que se
acepte que la incorporación de prueba a
la causa y a él en todo lo que va de
este proceso no le hicieron ninguna
pericia solamente tiene una pericia de
parte significa que es una pericia paga
por él así que si hay un estándar no una
idea de cuál es la buena víctima cuánto
tiempo una puede tardar en denunciar a
pesar de que hay estudios a nivel
internacional
cuentan que una víctima de abuso sexual
puede tardar en promedio 33 años en
poder hablar absolutamente
voy a citar algo que escribiste en
alguna oportunidad dijiste gracias al
guía a que alguien habló su pude hablar
y así transformamos las cadenas que nos
ataban en cadenas que nos unieron para
no sentirnos más a solas y animamos a
contar nuestras historias dijiste alguna
vez y tus palabras termas tuvieron ese
mismo efecto en otras mujeres que
aseguran que entendieron como vos
dijiste no que no estaban solas que no
les había sucedido a ellas solas es
fundamental lo colectivo no ese apoyo
esa contención del colectivo sobre todo
de mujeres
lo más fuerte que tuvo este proceso para
mí fue la comprensión de lo colectivo la
comprensión de que no estaba sola yo
estando en nicaragua le dije a mi mejor
amiga con quien viaje hacer la denuncia
porque me daba mucho miedo viajar sola
que si una persona del otro lado se
sentía identificada y acompañada y
sentía que no estaba ni sola ni loca
para mí era más que suficiente lo que
pasó después con mi denuncia pues para
mí mucho más grande de lo que jamás me
imaginé
aumentaron en 24 horas un 1.200 por
ciento las llamadas a la línea de
violencia de género
denunciando contando historias sobre
todo mujeres contando sus historias así
que creo que sí que de alguna forma la
reparación tiene que ver con eso con
haber logrado sacar este tema debajo de
la alfombra y haberlo puesto sobre la
mesa y que hoy lo debatamos y lo
hablemos y sepamos que no estamos solas
pero bueno además de lo duro no hoy de
todas las violencias que se viven
a través del proceso judicial me viste
otras violencias ha sido y sos quizás
vos me lo dirás banco de mensajes de
odio de una violencia extrema tema a
través de las redes sociales sobre todo
no donde reina el anonimato hay así como
una suerte de continuidad de esas otras
violencias y revictimización es que se
vienen durante el proceso judicial
por supuesto sin duda es lo más violento
viene de parte del sistema judicial por
lo avalado que está hay algo que es muy
fuerte que es sentir que tiene derecho a
la justicia a ponerte en ese lugar
entonces más violento que eso
prácticamente no hay nada no porque es
como si denunciar fuera exponerte otra
vez a ser abusada porque sos abusada de
muchos modos en ese proceso pero sin
dudas lo que hemos mencionadas en
relación a las redes sociales y este
momento tan virulento no donde yo creo
incluso que algunos estallidos sociales
no se producen porque se contienen en
esta especie de cloaca que se ha
convertido algunas redes sociales
particularmente twitter donde la
violencia que sufrimos quienes nos
atrevemos a hablar es una cosa
prácticamente y reproducible pero si
también te tengo que decir que eso es
una es algo que no se condice con lo que
me sucede en la calle no hay una
realidad tangible que yo salga a la
calle y que me encuentre con esa
violencia en la calle como me encuentro
con testimonios de apoyo de cariño
mucha emoción porque si no fuera en
primera persona quizás tienen un
pariente un familiar que se atrevió a
hablar a partir de mi denuncia que bueno
esto que contraste el ma esa es la
contracara de esos discursos tan odian
test ahora hay una reflexión que nos
llegan muchísimas personas y que vos
misma incluso la plantea este que tiene
que ver con que si con toda la
visibilidad no que tiene tu caso el
apoyo de las colegas de muchísimas
personas como contás qué ocurre en las
calles no logras justicia que esperar de
las personas que quizás son más no están
tan visibilizadas no que bien quizás más
al margen en este sentido es necesario
creemos una modificación de todo el
sistema judicial para que la justicia
llegue a todas
sin dudas para mí es muy doloroso
imaginar no sólo lo imagino lo conozco
porque trabajo con mujeres en nuestra
misma situación el trabajo me refiero
hago no venir simplemente porque conozco
del recorrido y es muy importante el
acompañamiento como decíamos antes en
relación a lo colectivo entonces las
acompañe en sus recorridos y justamente
no pensar que si yo estoy en esta
posición de tantos privilegios para
empezar soy una mujer blanca de clase
media y hetero tengo un montón de
cuestiones que son hetero no es la regla
de hegemonía y sin embargo mi voz es muy
difícil que llegue a penetrar en la
justicia
y del otro lado hay un poder muy claro
donde se evidencia que históricamente
las leyes han sido hechas por hombres y
para hombres de clase alta y en este
caso estamos frente a esa misma
situación que se reproduce a lo largo
del tiempo y no se ha revisado en el
mundo los códigos penales se han hecho
hace muchísimo tiempo y no se ha hecho
una revisión sobre cómo deben tratarse a
pesar de que las sociedades han avanzado
y ahora hablamos de estos temas con una
enorme diferencia antiguamente esto
bueno no solamente por ejemplo un
femicidio se decía que crimen pasional
sino que también las denuncias de abuso
sexual eran denuncias
que tenían que ver con con un agravio al
pudor o sea que era el pudor de la de la
víctima lo que estaba puesto en juego en
la casa el cambio de paradigma que
logramos todavía no logró penetrar en la
justicia para que los estándares de
probar los estándares probatorios sean
diferentes y garanticen cuando hace las
estadísticas santiago es muy duro las
estadísticas dicen que de 100 denuncias
solamente una consigue condena y eso no
quiere no quiere decir que haya 99
denuncias falsas lo que quiere decir es
que el estándar los estándares
probatorios son prácticamente imposibles
en el camino se quedan muchísimas porque
el sistema intenta quebrar de
silenciarte y porque si del otro lado te
estás enfrentando con alguien que tiene
herramientas sobre todo poder económico
y de influencia es muy difícil seguir
adelante y poder constituir una querella
que es significa en otros términos es
ser parte del proceso thelma luego que
luego de que se diera a conocer este
último durísimo revés no en la justicia
de brasil dijiste estoy cansada pero no
vencida de dónde sacas de esas fuerzas
del mar
sin dudas de toda esa gente que me cruzo
en la calle y que me pide que siga
luchando porque justamente se siente
identificada y siente que si yo no puedo
ellas - y entonces yo siento ahí una
gran responsabilidad porque mi causa se
convirtió en una causa que no es
personal sino que es profundamente
colectiva y desde ahí es que siento la
responsabilidad de sacar fuerzas a pesar
de que por supuesto reconozco el
cansancio tema para ir finalizando nos
queda poco menos de un minuto pero algo
que has dicho también y que quedó
resonando tiene que ver con una suerte
de adoctrinamiento quizás que está
buscando la justicia con este tipo de
fallos y estas decisiones
hay algo que es muy fuerte en mi caso
que así como el impacto colectivo que
tuvo a favor para que muchas personas se
animaron a hablar también es muy fácil
adoctrinar a través de un solo caso a
muchas otras mujeres no si vemos que en
mi caso no se consigue justicia muchas
otras van a hacer desalentadas a
animarse a hablar frente al red judicial
si es que tienen la posibilidad de sus
casos no están prescritos entonces es
muy importante que nosotras podamos
seguir haciendo este recorrido porque
además nos piden que vayamos a la
justicia y porque vivimos en una
sociedad organizada es importante que
podamos ir a la justicia que
construyamos una masa crítica y que
generemos un cambio en la justicia que
tenga que ser una justicia regional con
perspectiva de género no solamente en
harina no solamente en brasil donde
tramita mi causa sino en toda la región
y en el mundo una justicia con
perspectiva de género y por supuesto
respetuosa respetuosa de los derechos
humanos él me aparece muchísimas gracias
por estos minutos con transmití 4 ha
sido un placer dialogar contigo
gracias a un santiago agotados ustedes a
todo el equipo a vos te el mayor jala se
haga justicia a nuestra audiencia le
invitamos a seguir informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación gracias
por acompañarnos
[Música]